AI will either be one of three cliches
that it will be controlled by macro
entities like Google Microsoft Beijing
and the most dangerous of all Wall
Street that they will escape pervade
everywhere be infinitely duplicable and
have no boundaries or that they will
combine into a classic Sci-fi Skynet
dominate the world as in Terminator but
there is a path that if we were to
research it properly now it would work
because it already has human beings and
that is when you were attacked by a
feral predatory hyper intelligent being
as you have been in your life called a
lawyer what do you do you hire your own
predatory hyperintelligence being called
a lawyer that is the clue